the tampa bay buccaneers
have a second super bowl title in
franchise history
just in case you missed the memo the
tampa bay buccaneers won super bowl 55
on sunday night and for tom brady and
rob gronkowski
there was no better way to celebrate
than with their leading ladies
the best part about winning is having
the people
that have helped you get there and
support you there with you to enjoy it
gisele bundchen was on the sidelines at
raymond james stadium for the big game
in tampa florida
as tom and the bucks claimed a 31-9
victory
over the kansas city chiefs after the
big win
the supermodel hit up her insta story to
share this clip from inside the stadium
[Music]
hey jack baby
yeah the record-shattering quarterback
got a lot of love from his kiddos
eleven-year-old benjamin and
eight-year-old vivian whom he shares
with gisele
as well as 13 year old john whom he
shares with his ex bridget moynihan
that win marked tom's tenth super bowl
appearance and his
seventh super bowl win and he celebrated
out on the field with a heartfelt hug
from his wifey and his kids
but giselle wasn't the only proud
partner of a tampa bay buccaneer star on
sunday night
camille kostek celebrated her boyfriend
rob gronkowski's
super bowl win on instagram two sharing
this smooched up pick on the field
alongside the caption
tastes like a champion i love you gronk
the sports illustrated model who's been
dating rob since 2015
also shared this shot with her man and
his mom diane walters
writing can't think of a caption right
now i'm celebrating
yeah celebrating his fourth super bowl
win
and while rob and tom had their ladies
there to support them for the big win
some of hollywood's biggest stars were
there too
shania twain gave fans a look inside the
stadium
rebel wilson posed with some
cheerleaders and her pitch perfect
co-star adam devine
christina aguilera took a private jet to
tampa for the game
and so did alex rodriguez and jennifer
lopez
all right we're making uh some
predictions here jen who do you have
today
welcome back to you